les menaces sont effroyables
heureusement qu'elle a été protégé il
faut que ça cesse et elle a tout notre
soutien et après je suis entièrement
d'accord avec vous le problème c'est que
à force de stigmatiser les musulmans je
parle pas de l'émission en général et en
particulier mais en général si voilà tu
fais un petit pas une donnée essentielle
c'est vrai que l'on va on va les forcer
au repli et je gagne en force et au
communautarisme on va les forcer à vivre
entre eux et on va voir ce qu'on ne veut
pas voir c'est à dire des endroits ils
vont être entre eux il faut les intégrer
la religion musulmane c'est une religion
de l'ain team que chacun a envie
d'exprimer les intérêts pour la plus
intégrée je vais pas dire il faut les
intégrer ils sont tous intégrés je suis
désolé il y ait chez raymond gilly et
aujourd'hui ils disent on est on fait
tout bien et on est on est mis de côté
on est on est stigmatisée et c'est vrai
que ça devient très compliqué aussi moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on fasse un suivi
gorge d'en faire une émission là dessus
je vais inviter des personnes voilà qui
sont vraiment dans un désarroi total qui
viendront témoigner dans cette émission
dans les prochains jours je vous dis
parce que c'était un témoignage que
j'entends de plus en plus aussi
géraldine maillet sur ophélie meunier
bien sûr c'est inadmissible oui c'est
alors est ce que est ce que c'est ce que
c'est devenu trop dangereux d'enquêter
par praticien derrière ophélie mais bien
sûr que l'on brasse fort ophélie
beaucoup plus des journées il faudrait
qu'elle fasse la une du monde voudrait
qu'elle soit en dernière page de libé je
trouve que tous les journaux devraient
la soutenir à 100% sans mais sans
tortiller oui mais
voilà elle devenait trop dangereux oui
mais faut vraiment la soutenir parce que
je trouve que c'est incroyable
aujourd'hui les journalistes ils sont
menacés dans les dictatures dans les
piles autoritaire et donc ça n'est pas
normal qu'en france des journalistes
soient menacés ça c'est le premier point
et ensuite parler de l'islam radical est
ce que c'est dangereux aujourd'hui je
pense que c'est un sujet qui peut être
compliqué weck est clivant et compliqué
même nous quand on en parle ici autour
de la table parfois on et ben vous
insultez peu importe mais menacé
effectivement ce je trouve que ça n'est
pas normal on a le droit de critiquer
les religions toutes les religions les
ont pas une car un traitement de faveur
oui mais au delà des menaces évidemment
qui sont condamnables ya une
récupération politique est faite qui est
terrible et qui nous fait croire que dès
qu'on parle de l'islam radical et même
de l'islam il ya des menaces
immédiatement que les musulmans et tous
les musulmans se met à insulter tout le
monde à être menaçant je suis désolé
mais c'est faux et voilà je me suis fait
polémique elle fait aussi
d'autres polémiquer sur ce reportage à
savoir qu'ils étaient à charge et que
voilà il y avait des méthodes essayez
pas très journalistique pour pour sa
fabrication mais c'est pas une raison
évidemment les faux-pas jamais justifier
les menaces voilà mais je trouve qu une
récupération politique qui peut prêter à
des clichés des amalgames qui sont pas
très joyeux voilà c'est mathieu d'abord
la pauvre fils il faut quand même
rappeler qu'elle est présentatrice elle
n'est pas les prises en chef c'est après
elle est elle était en cabine de ce pic
pour faire des tests même si elle les
fait très bien et tout ça c'est des
textes qu'elle a écrits enfin c'est elle
qui incarne ben oui elle incarne va
porter une émission qui aiderait à
cannes la nuit tourné unis écrit sur
donc c'est évidemment très violents pour
elle après il faut être très honnête oui
c'est un sujet qui est devenu
aujourd'hui extrêmement extrêmement
délicat islam ou même islam radical même
juste non non et c'est devant attention
non mais même juste c'est venu très très
très sage et très punchy on fait très
attention à ceux connus en plateau
parce que voilà on a toujours peur de
déraper des dans le mauvais maul le et
chaque mot est pesé et c'est vrai que
c'est c'est enfin en tout cas moi je
parle pour moi mais je sais un sujet
dans le futur je t'adore que je ne
maîtrise pas assez d'accord d'accord je
maîtrise pas assez pour donner mon avis
qui sera souvent et bio sur le sujet
donc je préfère me taire parce que c'est
le sait on a peur